two nurses lauded by three world leaders
Jenny McGee from New Zealand and her
colleague Louise pitamah from Portugal
part of the critical care team that
nursed the Prime Minister through
intensive care I hope they won't mind if
I mention in particular two nurses who
stood by my bedside for 48 hours when
things could have gone either way there
Jenny from New Zealand Invercargill on
the South Island to be exact and Luis
from Portugal near Porto Boris Johnson
says he owes his life to the staff at
st. Thomas's including Jenny McGee and
so does David cotton he was admitted to
the ICU at Guy's Hospital after
suffering a seizure jenny was the head
nurse on his unit an intensive care unit
can be quite a scary place what was it
about her that made you feel reassured
he's all these noises and machines and
ventilators and all kinds of electronic
measuring equipment is going off alarms
and somebody like Jenny she's kind of
master of all she surveys but at the
same time keeping calm and throwing in
the odd you know joke and comment keep
his spirits up and I would imagine she
would have gone perfectly with Boris Don
because she wouldn't have taken any any
trap from him she would have she was
have definitely told him what she
expected from him what she would be
doing to look after him and how she
wanted him to behave and that the
personality she is back in New Zealand
Jenny's parents woke up to the news that
their daughter had helped to save the
life of the British prime minister she
said she had just had a most surreal
time in her life something she will
never forget and they
she had been taking care of Boris
Johnson is now recovering at checkers
Jenni is back on the front line do you
think she'll be embarrassed by all this
praise those people in the profession
just see it is going to work and I don't
think that they understand the profound
effect it has
you know something I'll never forget
when you put your life in their hands
you really do need them to be there for
you and certainly she was she was
outstanding absolutely out Bambi Jennie
and Louise have both been praised by
their country's leaders they are two of
the International NHS family quietly
bravely saving the lives of prime
ministers and patients alike
Ashish Joshi Sky News